bonjour et bienvenue dans les grands
débats la rédaction de LCP vous fait
revivre le meilleur des discussions sur
les grandes loi voté à l'Assemblée
nationale au cœur de la séance publique
alors nous sommes le 25 septembre 2023 à
l'ordre du jour un projet de loi pour
favoriser le plein emploi le
gouvernement a un but très clair il veut
faire baisser le taux de chômage à 5 %
de la population active d'ici à 2027 et
pour cela son texte déjà voté au Sénat
prévoit la transformation de Pôle emploi
en France travail à la tribune le
ministre fixe le cap devant la
représentation
nationale je suis très heureux de vous
retrouver au début de cette section
extraordinaire pour présenter devant
vous le projet de loi pour le plein
emploi vous le savez depuis 2017 sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
les gouvernements successifs et notre
majorité poursuivent un objec majeur le
plein EMP nous voulons le plein emploi
car nous sommes convaincus que derrière
cet objectif il y a plus qu'un résultat
statistique du marché du travail c'est
en réalité un projet de société CELI
d'une société plus productive et donc
plus riche et plus souveraine mais
également une société qui donne une
place à chacun car l'emploi nous
l'affirmons nous le réaffirmons l'accès
à l'emploi reste le meilleur moyen et
l'outil plus efficace pour lutter contre
la pauvreté pour donner au R de
l'autonomie de la dignité et ainsi
permettre l'émancipation il y a encore
quelques années parler de plein emploi
aurait suscité au mieux des mot
dubitatives au pire des sarcasmes tant
nous nous sommes habitués à vivre avec
le chômage de masse l'état disait-on
avait tout fait avait fait tout ce qu'il
pouvait la puissance publique était
finalement dans une impasse et une forme
de fatalisme collectif nous avait saisi
conférant au plein emploi le rendune
belle utopie à l'horizon sans cesse
repoussée ce fatalisme en réalité est
mortifère et il explique largement ce
qui semble être comme un décrochage
productif quand on constate après ces
décennies de résignation que notre taux
d'emploi reste plus de 10 point point
inférieur à la moyenne européenne quand
on voit aussi que notre produit
intérieur brut par habitant est 15 à 20
% inférieur à ceux de l'Allemagne ou du
Danemarc revenir au niveau de ces
économies rarement considéré comme des
îos ultralibéraux ou de servitude
apporterait à nos finances publicqus des
recettes rendant l'idé même de déficit
totalement inopérante et donc c'est pour
faire mentir tout cela que nous agissons
depuis 2017 nous avons fait une partie
du chemin c'est 6 dernières années vous
le savez puisqu'en passant de 9,5 à 7,1
% le taux de chômage est au plus depuis
40 ans et le taux d'emploi le taux
d'activité sont au plus haut depuis que
l'INC les mesure en
1975 aujourd'hui nous le croyons et nous
le savons nous sommes en mesure
d'atteindre le plein emploi et pour
finir de nous donner les moyens
d'atteindre cet objectif nous nous
réformons donc le service public de
l'emploi nous modernisons
l'accompagnement des plus fragiles et
nous continuons à lever les freins à
l'emploi que connaissent trop de nos
concitoyens je pense notamment nous y
reviendrons à ceux en situation de
handicap nous appuyons en réalité notre
marche et ce texte sur un constat et une
conviction le constat c'est que les
entreprises peinent à recruter alors que
le chômage reste encore important parmi
les taux les plus importants en Europe
cela signifie que nous avons du mal à
résoudre cette inadéquation entre la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi et les
besoins des entreprises que nous devons
aussi donner plus d'efficacité à notre
service public de l'emploi pour faire se
rencontrer l'offre et la demande de
travail la conviction c'est que personne
n'est inemployable et ce projet de loi
doit permettre au marché du travail
d'inclure ceux qui sont les plus
éloigner de l'emploi de rendre de un
emploi au plus fragile ca même qui
pendant des décennies ont été relogués
au second au second rang par la la
fatalité du chômage de masse souvent au
mêmes endroits et souvent les mêmes la
réforme du RSA le Revenu de Solidarité
Active est au cœur du projet de loi le
gouvernement veut conditionner le
versement de cette aide à la réalisation
d'un certain nombre d'heures d'activité
il défend un véritable projet de société
et souhaite accompagner ceux qui sont
les plus éloignés de
l'emploi le premier volet de ce projet
de loi concerne donc l'accompagnement
des plus éloignés de l'emploi et il y a
certains constats qui sonnent comme des
alertes 60 % des allocataires sont
toujours inscrits au RSA plus de 5 ans
après leur première inscription 42 % le
sont toujours après 7 ans et 16 %
desocataires sont même encore sont même
encore inscrits plus de 10 ans après
leur première inscription ce n'est pas
ainsi que la République s'acquite de son
devoir de solidarité et il faut en finir
je crois avec le totem de l'aide contre
la pauvreté qui passe que sans
contrepartie serait paressance meilleure
que toutes les autres et ce même si en
réalité elle enferme une large partie de
ceux qui en bénéficient dans la misère
et dans la précarité faire preuve de
solidarité ça n'est pas accepter que ce
cré des trappes à précarité et ça n'est
pas atténuer les symptômes de la
précarité qui ont fait disparaître les
causes c'est d'être accompagné
globalement d'être inséré par le travail
dont ont besoin les plus fragiles je
l'ai dit je le répète la République
n'est pas quitte de son devoir de
solidarité quand elle a vers 7 € par
mois à quelqu'un elle est quand elle lui
a rendu les moyens de son autonomie et
les moyens d'accéder à l'emploi et avec
ce projet de loi nous voulons donc tenir
pour de bon la promesse de solidarité
qui est celle duursa et ce avec une
série de mesures
concrètes ne parle pas de travail vous
ne connaissez pas s'il vous plaît
d'abord l'ensemble des personnes en
recherche d'emploers collèges et
notamment laissez monsieur le ministre
s'exprimer parleite mesames et messieurs
les députés à vouser mais sur ce dont
vous ce que vous connaissez je n'ai pas
le sentiment que le travail et l'emploi
soit vre première
spécialité d'abord je le
dis l'ensemble des personnes en
recherche d'emploi et notamment
l'ensemble des advocataires du RSA des
jeunes en recherche d'emploi accompagné
par les missions locales seront
inscrites auprès de l'opérateur France
travail c'est le meilleur moyen de
garantir un accompagnement à chacun et
d'éviter les ruptures de parcours pour
les plus isolés le projet de loi prévoit
la reconnaissance et la la sécurisation
des acteurs souvent associatifs chargé
de repérer d'aller vers les personnes
qui ne sont plus suivies aujourd'hui par
aucune structure pour leur proposer des
solution d'accompagnement et d'insertion
adapté comme l'insertion par le sport
par la culture mais pas seulement bien
sûr ces acteurs reconnus seront intégrés
au réseau France travail pour qu'on ne
perde aucune des solutions qui March
ensuite le parcours d'accompagnement
sera formalisé dans le cadre d'un
contrat d'engagement rénové et unifié
pour plus de lisibilité et d'efficacité
ce nouveau contrat d'engagement sera
proposé à tous les demandeurs emploi
quelle que soit leur situation il
détaillera les engagements réciproques
de l'organisme référent et de la
personne accompagnée il intégrera un
plan d'action précisant les objectifs
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
du demandeur d'emploi et c'est important
de le souligner il tiendra compte de la
situation de la personne après un
diagnostic complet il pourra d'abord
être la personne pourra d'abord être
orientée vers un parcours àisé
d'insertion sociale si c'est nécessaire
pour lever les freins rencontré en
matière de logement de garde d'enfant de
santé de mobilité avant le parcours
d'insertion professionnelle il sera par
exemple tenu compte de la situation des
proches aons des familles monoparentales
qui n'ont pas de solution de garde et je
tiens d'emblé à souligner que le Sénat
enrichi le texte sur ce point que j'ai
pu constater combien votre commission
des affaires sociales est aussi attachée
ensuite le régime de contrôle et de
sanction des allocataires du RSA sera
rénové pour être plus progressif mais
aussi plus effectif un nouveau premier
niveau de sanction est introduit la
suspension remobilisation qui permettra
de suspendre temporairement la loocation
au manquement sans interrompre
l'accompagnement et si la personne
respecte ses engagements elle
bénéficiera d'un versement rétroactif
des droits à défaut il ira
malheureusement vers une radiation du
RSA comme c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
comme c'est le cas depuis
1988 cette nouvelle sanction sera
exercée par le président du conseil
départemental dans le plein respect de
ses prérogativ et de ses compétences
enfin dans l'esprit du contrat
d'engagement jeune ce nouveau contrat
permettra de proposer un accompagnement
intensif et personnalisé pour les
allocataires du RSA les plus éloignés de
l'emploi France travail proposera ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin selon que
permet leur situation personnelle
jusqu'à 15 à 20h hebdomadaires
d'activités consacrées à leur parcours
atelier formation accompagnement appui
solution local il s'agit ni de travail
gratuit ni de bénévolent obligatoire
mais bien d'activités d'insertion et de
formation pour permettre le retour à
l'emploi cet accompagnement sera aussi
renforcé par la prise en compte des
difficultés de nature sociale qui
empêche le retour à l'emploi la réforme
du RSA est au cœur des attentions
critiqué par la gauche qui estime que
cela va pénaliser les plus fragiles les
plus pauvres mais défendu par les
républicains qui jugent la réforme
nécessaire de quoi donner lieu à de très
nombreuses pass
d'armes voilà qu'un gouvernement de
millionnaires et ses collaborateurs le
péniste veulent retirer 500 balles aux
familles qui se battent au quotidien
pour
survivre manœuvre absolument détestable
qui consiste à leur faire payer vos
erreurs car ce projet n'est que l'acte 2
de votre réforme des retraites nous vous
l'avions dit à l'époque que repousser
âge de départ à la retraite créerit
automatiquement des allocataires du RSA
puisque les chômeurs âgés doivent tenir
2 ans de plus sans que les droits ne
soient
proroger nous vous l'avions dit à
l'époque que repousser l'âge de départ
créit des travailleuses et travailleurs
en situation de handicap puisqueaprès 60
ans plus d'un accident du travail sur 6
cause des dommages irréversibles pour le
reste de l'existence de la personne qui
lui bloque le bras le dos les jambes ou
autres et nous y voilà nous y voilà vous
savez que des dizaines de de personnes
vont basculer au RSA vous savez des
dizaines de milliers de personnes vont
subir une situation de handicap et comme
d'habitude vous réfléchissez avec 6 mois
de
retard alors j'imagine qu'un ministre a
dû se dire moi qui gagnais un RSA par
demi-journée avant d'être élu je connait
bien le dossier et que vous êtes
concerté pour pondre cette idée aussi
farfelue que simpliste inscrire tout le
monde tout le monde sur la liste des
demandeuses et demandeurs d'emploi
chôeur bien sûr mais aussi personnes en
situation de handicap à locataire du RSA
leors qu'joint avec alors pour l'instant
vous épargnez les gosses on est encore
content jusqu'aux Invalides même
jusqu'aux Invalides même que vous
vouliez obliger à rechercher un emploi
qui ne peuvent par définition pas
occuper heureusement sur ce point on
vous a battu en commission la semaine
dernière
alors pourquoi pourquoi inscrire tout le
monde sur la liste des demandeuses et
demandeurs d'emploi et bien pour les
obliger à signer un nouveau bout de
papier que vous avez inventé qui
s'appelle le contrat d'engagement alors
de toute façon vu que vous ne recrutez
pas d'agents supplémentaires les
nouveaux inscrits ne verront qu'un
courrier dans la boîte aux lettres ou un
email puisque aujourd'hui d'ors et déjà
20 % des allocataires du RSA n'ont pas
accès à un accompagnement en dépit des
engagements de l'État mais désormais
avec votre contrat s'il déroge à l'une
des clauses et bien pouf on leur coupe
absolument tout jusqu'au moindre euros
évidemment si l'état de son côté ne
remplit pas ses obligations il ne se
passera absolument rien mais à quel
moment vous êtes-vous dit qu'on aidit
les gens en les plongeant dans la misère
c'est tout même une question qui nous
dépasse si quelqu'un n'a plus un rond
sur son compte courant évidemment qu'il
ne va pas aller au Forum de l'Emploi
évidemment qu'il va pas faire le plein
pour aller à Pô emploi évidemment qu'il
ou qu' ne va pas revoir ses anciens
collègues pour savoir ce qu'il en est
dans le secteur d'activité et les
députés macronistes l'ont d'ailleurs
admis la semaine dernière en commission
vous avez dit avec 500 € de RSA on ne
vit pas on survit et en dépit de ce
propos vous estimez la survie est
conditionnelle vous nous dites des
individus peuvent être privés du droit
de survivre s'ils ne répondent pas à des
contrats d'engagement donc c'est une
logique morale que nous n'acceptons pas
parce qu'un être humain a le droit de
continuer à exister quoi qu'il en soit
sans aucune condition jamais car il est
toujours notre frère ou notre sœur en
humanité quel que soit son comportement
son parcours son histoire ses proches ou
son
activité et mesurez bien la cruauté de
ce que vous faites si un demandeur ou
une demandeuse emploi rate un
rendez-vous par exemple en visio parce
que la wifi est en rade qui se trompe
d'adresse pour se rendre à une de vos
formations de qualité formation postite
ou coloriage on sait jamais trop bref si
jamais il se trompe qu'il se qu'il
commet cette erreur on lui retire
absolument tout à loocation chômage mais
aussi le RSA qui est une allocation
familiale versé donc pour l'adulte
bénéficiaire mais aussi pour la famille
et ses enfants donc demain je traduis
pour une Wii en panne ou un GPS qui ne
marche pas des gamins ne seront plus
soignés n'auront plus le droit à des
fournitures scolaires ou n'iront plus à
la
cantine d'autant qu'au début vous nous
racontiez des salades comme quoi ces 15h
serviraient à découvrir des association
faire du théâtre réussir à se découvrir
soi-même je ne sais pas quoi et mardi
dernier à 22h10 en commission monsieur
le rapporteur a vendu la mèche il nous a
confirmé face caméra tout le monde
pourra vérifier que ces heures
obligatoires comprendraient des stages
des immersions situation de travail de
la mise en poste simulé ou du bénévola
alors vous avez inventé le bénévola
force c'est une contradiction dans les
termes on croirait entendre macroniste
de gauche et du même registre et tout
cela très chers collègues macroniste ou
le péniste je vais vous confier un
secret et bien les stages les formations
en milieu de travail la simulation et
ben c'est du travail tout ça c'est du
travail et dès lors même si ça vous
déplaît il y a encore des lois dans ce
pays qui imposent que le travail soit
rémunéré sauf que le travail Vous vous
ne l'aimez qu'à condition qu'il soit
gratuit et non
payé dès lors lorsque vous dites France
travaille et bien permettez-nous
d'entendre France extorsion d'autant
plus que si vous trouvez 15 heures
d'activité non payée à imposer à 7
millions de bénéficiire et bien j'ai une
bonne nouvelle pour vous ça veut dire
que vous avez trouvé de quoi embaucher 3
millions de gens à temps plein sauf que
là il va falloir les payer et sortir le
portefeuille
évidemment je veux donc sonner ici
l'alerte pour toutes les salariés et
tous les salariés du pays déjà depuis un
an le pouvoir d'achat des salaires a
reculé de 2 % face à ça les seuls qui
n'ont aucune obligation à l'égard de la
République sont les plus grands patrons
ou les grands actionnaires qui chaque
année détourne l'équivalent de 9 années
de RSA et eux aucun contrat d'engagement
n'est prévu pour les remettre dans le
droit chemin pour eux rien pas
d'obligation le gavage c'est offert
c'est payé maison mais demain si on
laisse faire le gouvernement les
salariés doivent bien comprendre qu'il
risque d'avoir à leur côté sur les
postes de travail des stagiaires des
personnes en formation qui ont é placé
là de manière involontaire c'est-à-dire
de force c'est un ehémisme pour le dire
et c'est une menace pour celles et ceux
qui sont mal payés et seront mis en
concurrence avec des personnes qui
exercent une activité qui peut s'y
substituer pour une rémunération
absolument nulle sur le lieu de travail
d'ailleurs les employeurs du pays ne le
demandent même pas ils savent très bien
que tout cela va désorganiser l'outil de
production passer 2 jours par cite 2
jours par là avec des personnes qui
n'ont pas demandé à être dans ce type de
secteur ou ce type d'entreprise va créer
un jeu de bento gén généralisé où chacun
rêvera d'être dans la boîte d'à côté et
où personne n'ira au travail avec un
minimum de bonne humeur de motivation et
donc d'acquisition de
qualification et ces 15 heures
d'activité obligatoire sont imposé il
faut le rappeler à toutes et tous les
demandeurs d'emploi vous avez fait 35
ans de boulot dans l'aéronautique un
licenciement vous êtes concerné par Unat
d'engagement vous êtes agriculteur une
mauvaise récolte ou une grippe aviare
vous passer au RSA pour les non salariés
agricoles vous êtes concerné par le
contrat d'engagement vous êtes mè isolé
occupé à ongl avec l'emploi du temps
l'activité des enfants que vous avez à
charge vous êtes concernés vous êtes en
situation de handicap bloqué dans
certains mouvements fondamentaux de la
vie et bien vous êtes concerné alors oui
le gouvernement se gargarise d'ouvrir
aux travailleurs en situation de
handicap en AAT des droits identiques à
tous les travailleurs et toutes les
travailleuses sauf sauf le droit le plus
essentiel celui au salaire alors bravo
vous avez inventer le salariat sans le
salaire superbe invention superbe idée
je sais pas comment vous faites si c'est
ça l'idé que vous avez quand vous
réfléchissez à 200 on n pas envie de
voir les petits comités bref quoi qu'il
en soit au prétexte que quelqu'un
travaille en AAT vous payez sa force de
travail deux fois moins que sur le
marché du travail extérieur ce qui est
inacceptable dès lors dès lors lorsque
le ministre emploie l'expression
personne n'est inemployable il faut bien
comprendre ce qu'il veut dire personne
n'est inexploitable c'est bien ça l'idée
fondamentale le fil rouge de ce texte
c'est que personne ne peut d'être
protégé d'aller boucher les trous sur le
marché du travail pour les emplois qui
sont les plus indignes et qui ne
trouvent pas preneurs ni preneus et ce a
raison c'est pour cela c'est pour cela
que vous confiez l'orientation des
personnes en situation de handicap aux
agents de France travail plutôt qu'aux
maisons départemental des personnes
handicapées vous les confiez à des
agents qui ne sont pas former à la
condition des personnes en handicap pour
vous assurer qu'il les dirigent vers des
postes inadaptés à elle et à eux ça
semble absurde oui forcément vous l'avez
voté jeudi dans la nuit à 3h du mat et
donc dans ce texte il n'y a pas un mot
il n'y a pas un mot sur la logique
inverse tous ces postes de travail qui
produisent du handicap tous ces postes
de travail où le déficit de protection
ou le déficit de ou disons les défauts
de machinerie peuvent exposer la
personne à une blessure laquelle en
retour devient une situation de handicap
pour l'ensemble de son existence voici
la formule de ce texte plutôt que de
protéger ensemble des postes de travail
pour limiter l'exposition à des
blessures graves en établissant des
contraintes fortes sur le grand patronat
on met la pression sur les gens pour
qu'ils aillent vers n'importe quel
boulot y compris ceux qui mutilent et
ceux qui
handicapent évidemment évidemment comme
en témoigne la grève prévue demain dans
le service public d'emploi les
conseillers et conseillères pour
l'emploi n'acceptent pas que vous les
empêcher d'aider leur public il
n'accepte pas de recevoir 3 millions de
personnes en plus à effectif constant et
j'adresse d'ailleurs d'ici au nom de mon
groupe un salut fraternel à toutes les
conseillères et conseillers pour
l'emploi qui tiennent bon qui refusent
de radier les chômeurs même lorsqu'on
leur demande et qui refuse de les forcer
à accepter des offres illégales ou
indignes monsieur Clouet la situation
sur le plan du chômage n'est pas bonne
elle est très
mauvaise nous sommes 25e 23e sur 27 dans
l'Union européenne donc nous ne sommes
pas parmi les mauvais élèves nous sommes
des mauvais élèves et vous vous nous
dites et vous vous nous dites surtout
tout va mal mais on ne débat de rien
mais comment voulez-vous que les choses
changent monsieur Clouet un député il
est payé pourquoi il est payé pour que
la loi améliore les conditions de vie
des Français vous nous dites tout va mal
mais surtout mesdames et messieurs
rentrez chez vous ne discutez pas c'est
inaudible alors nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur le fond pas d'accord du
tout nous l'avons vu la semaine dernière
en commission des affaires sociales vous
vous considérez que le RSA c'est un
droit inconditionnel nous croyons
absolument
l'inverse nous pensons qu'en face du RSA
il doit y avoir des contreparties mais
c'est un sujet
important passionnant et vous voulez
l'évacuer en ne le discutant pas alors
Monsieur Clouet prenez le risque du
débat c'est la démocratie vous verrez ça
fait du
bien
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame Anne bergantz et à
Madame Anne bergantz uniquement s'il
vous plaît merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues de la France insoumise
il est il est clair il est clair que
nous ne lisons pas et ne comprenons pas
les textes de la même façon durant
toutes vos interventions en commission
vous n'avez eu de cess de voir derrière
chaque article chaque alinéa une attaque
contre les demandeurs d'emploi et les
allocataires nous voyons au contraire
dans ce texte un progrès porté par une
meilleure gouvernance et coordination
des acteurs au plus près des territoires
mais aussi une volonté ambitieuse une
volonté ambitieuse de miser sur
l'accompagnement des demandeur d'emploi
et des entreprises oui ce PGL mise sur
l'accompagnement sur l'humain et nous le
savons c'est ce qui fonctionne par cette
motion de rejet vous estimez donc
qu'aucune des mesures présentes dans ce
texte ne saurait avoir une incidence
positive somme vous considérez que mieux
accompagner les 1,9 millions de foyers
bénéficiaires du RSA vers un parcours
social socio-professionnel professionnel
ou une formation n'est pas une avancée
vous considérez qu'améliorer le service
public de la petite enfance pour
notamment aider les 160000 femmes
empêcher de chercher un emploi faute de
solution de garde n'est pas une avancée
vous considérez enfin que mieux
accompagner reconnaître la qualité de
travailleurs handicapés et ses
spécificités ainsi que les droits des
milliers de personnes travaillant en les
ates n'est pas une avancée en somme vous
considérez que tout va bien et qu'il est
urgent de ne rien changer ne rien faire
pour les demandes d'emploi voici votre
programme j'ai assisté à toutes les
auditions à toutes les auditions et j'ai
pu constater que la casi intégralité des
acteurs de l'emploi était favorable à ce
PGL il y a eu des suggestions
d'amélioration évidemment certaines ont
été satisfaite par des amendements
acceptés en commission qu'ell viennent
de la majorité ou de l'opposition et
d'autres pourraient intervenir dans le
cadre de la séance nous croyons nous
démocrates fondamentalement que le
travail est source d'émancipation
d'insertion de réinsertion et œuvre à la
réduction de la pauvreté notre groupe
votera contre cette motion de rejet
préalable je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Arthur de la porte
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues
est-ce que vous voulez bien
entrer discrètement dans les hémicycles
pour que que Monsieur de laaporte puisse
s'exprimer dans de bonnes conditions
vous avez la parole chers
collègues merci madame la Présidente ce
texte sur le plein emploi est bien loin
d'être plein il s'organise autour d'un
grand vide vide de sens vide de moyens
vide de tout ce qui manqué pour réparer
notre contrat social abîmé par vos
réformes successives cell de la assurant
chômage celle des retraites ce texte il
est mal ficelé il est baclé vous osez
tout de même le présenter ici sans étude
d'impact sans aucune analyse finalement
du rôle des sanctions rien non plus sur
l'impact sur l'égalité femme-homme quand
les femmes sont les allocataires du
ressa les plus pauvres aucun retour sur
les expérimentations bref s'il vous
plaît votre amateurisme ce sont aussi
les changements de pied permanent un
jour ça s'appelle France travail le
lendemain ça s'appelle Pôle emploi
le lendemain ça se rappelle France
travail et puis finalement France
travail devient le rail le réseau des
acteurs de l'insertion et de l'emploi
curieuse terminologie et finalement P
emploi devient France travail bref
comprennent qui pourra on en finit
surtout avec l'insertion et
l'inscription automatique et forcé des
allocataires du RSA comme des demandeurs
d'emploi vous inscrivez même ceux qui ne
peuvent pas travailler vous inscrivez
même les conjoints qui travaille déjà il
a raison comment se satisfaire d'un
texte où les sujets majeurs le handicap
la petite enfance se trouve insérée
foruitement alors qu'ils auraient mérité
de plus grandes ambitions et de
véritables débats et de véritables
textes nous en aurions volontiers
discuté en commission si ce texte
n'avait pas été adopté au forceps en
catimini et au milieu de la nuit à aucun
moment ce texte ne pose des sujets qui
font qu'on ne retrouve pas un emploi
niveau de rémunération qualité
pénibilité de l'emploi à aucun moment il
ne considère véritablement et
sérieusement les fr périphérique
mobilité par exemple depuis que n avons
depuis que nous avons chiffré votre
projet à 10 milliards d'euros jamais
nous avons été contredits ces milliards
nécessaires ils sont pourtant absents C
son là la plaisanterie car elle est
tragique votons cette motion de rejet
voil je vais donc mettre au voix la
motion de rejet
préalable merci de regagner vos
places le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est
[Applaudissements]
fermé donc votant 229 exprimés 210
majorités 106 pour 62 contre 149
l'Assemblée nationale n'a donc pas
adopté cette motion de rejet
préalable de l'autre côté de l'hémicycle
dans les rangs du rassemblement national
on estime nécessaire de légiférer sur
sur le sujet du chômage et de
l'insertion mais on estime aussi que le
texte pénalise les plus
pauvres ce texte était censé traiter de
la problématique de l'emploi dans notre
pays il est pourtant clair qu'il s'est
égaré de son objectif initial notre pays
connait une situation sociale
extrêmement tendue les Français
subissent au quotidien l'inflation la
perte progressive de leur pouvoir
d'achat mais aussi la montée de la
violence et de l'insécurité il n'est pas
concevable monsieur le ministre dans un
tel contexte de demander à celles et
ceux qui vivent déjà avec presque rien
de faire encore plus d'efforts il n'est
pas concevable de demander aux personnes
en situation de handicap aux
prochesdents et aux parents isolés de
faire abstraction de leur situation et
de leurs obligations pour faire encore
plus d'effort il n'est pas concevable
monsieur le ministre de demander à
celles et ceux qui ont travaillé qui ont
cotisé et qui ont obtenu des droits
d'abandonner ces droits de les
conditionner à un contrat d'engagement
irréalisable et de faire encore plus
d'efforts il n'est pas concevable
monsieur le ministre d'appeler un projet
de loi plein emploi lorsque que vous
excluez les jeunes de ce texte que vous
accordez des mettes aux travailleurs
handicapés et aux professionnels de la
petite enfance il n'est pas concevable
monsieur le ministre près d'un an après
la réforme des retraites de ne pas
inclure les Seigneur dans ce projet
votre chance d'agir pour nos aîné était
là et vous ne l'avez pas saisi votre
texte n'est qu'un camouflé qui vise une
nouvelle fois à opprimer un peu plus nos
concitoyens les moins fortunés à renier
nos droits et acquis sociaux et qui
montre à nouveau le véritable visage
hypocrite de la macronie cette macronie
qui se fiche de la vie des Français qui
se fiche de savoir si ces derniers
pourront terminer la semaine tant qu'il
Contin continuent de travailler même
dans les pires conditions pour autant
nous reconnaissons la nécessité absolue
de légiférer sur ce sujet le plein
emploi est un objectif de que tout
gouvernement se doit de poursuivre dans
l'intterri de nos concitoyens c'est
pourquoi il nous a paraît essentiel de
débattre de ce texte dans cet hémicycle
de faire valoir nos positions de faire
valoir nos idées par le débat par le
vote et non par le rejet je vous
remercie
pour faire passer sa réforme le
gouvernement a besoin du soutien des
députés les républicains ces derniers
voient d'un très bon œil la réforme du
RSA mais ils ont leur ligne rouge ils
conditionnent leur vote à l'inscription
dans la loi d'un certain nombre
d'activités obligatoire pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA débat tendu en
séance donc l'amendement 183 présenté
par Monsieur Juvin au nom du groupe les
républicains précise à la fois que la
durée puiss être réduite en fonction du
diagnostic et de la situation
individuelle de la personne et que les
personnes présentant des difficultés
particulières et avéré puissent être
exclu totalement de l'application de
cette durée d'activité minimum ce qui
vient compléter nos travaux en
commission la rédaction trouvée apporte
des gardesfous nécessaires chers
collègues pour bien préciser que les 15
heures d'activité domomadaire n'ont pas
vocation à s'appliquer strictosensus
pour l'ensemble des demandeurs puisque
nous avons les Gard de fous sur la
situation particulière des uns et des
autres sur le fait que vous vouliez
borni l'engagement à 20h je ne suis pas
favorable à une limite qui pourrait être
finalement contreproductive si un
demandeur suit par exemple une formation
plus longue à nécessité de dépasser donc
ce Cotat
horaire enfin le supprime donc le rôle
du comité donc je reste favorable au
1844 et
1852 je vais assez vite pour pas prendre
trop de votre
temps vous souhaitez supprimer la
possibilité que le nombre d'heur
d'activité soit nul cette pr fait partie
de équilibre trouvé donc sur la
rédaction proposée par Monsieur Juvin et
le gouvernement vous souhaitez que les
cacités ne soi pas exhaustif à nouveau
je rappelle que le diagnostic global
servant à l'élaboration du plan d'action
fera état de tous les obstacles
personnels du demandeur qui justifiera
un programme d'activité plus progressif
donc voilà donc je vous demanderai donc
évidemment de voter l'amendement du
Gouvernement et les deux les deux
sousamend du gouvernement pardon et
l'amendement de Monsieur Juvin et j'ai
bien évidé favorable sur les autres je
vous remerci monsieur le
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur l' vie du gouvernement est
connu je l'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
nous considérons que l'amendement porté
par Monsieur Juvin est un amendement qui
va dans dans le bon sens puisqu'il
permet à la fois de de fixer cet
objectif avec 15 heures d'activité et de
prévoir des adaptations pour une montée
en charge progressive tout en disant que
le service public de l'emploi et de
l'insertion ne doit pas baisser les bras
et que chacun doit pouvoir être
accompagné même peu mais accompagné pour
pouvoir revenir vers l'emploi le
gouvernement a déposé deux amendements
qui apportent des précisions
rédactionnelles not sur la méthodologie
ce qu'on appelle parfois la comitologie
que le gouvernement évidemment soutient
les autres amendements monsieur le
rapporteur les a évoqués limités et et
plafonné serait contreproductif avec
certaines formations et pour le reste
ils sont satisfaits par le corps de
l'amendement donc favorable au 183
défavorable à tous les sous-amendements
à l'exception de ceux qui sont
évidemment déposés par le gouvernement
je vous remercie nous allons passer au
débat alors comme c'est un sujet
important je vais prendre plus qu'un
pour un contre j'ai plusieurs demandes
de parole je vais commencer ave monsieur
daréille
merci madame la Présidente bien donc
voilà là on est au cœur de l'arrangement
au cœur de l'arrangement que vous avez
passé avec les républicains c'est une
discussion qui a commencé à se nouer au
Sénat au Sénat vous aviez expliqué vous
étiez en désaccord avec le fait
d'inscrire dans la loi les 15h vous avez
changé d'avis alors c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de se plaindre que vous
écoutiez un peu le Parlement je
reconnais euh cela dit vous écoutez pas
la bonne partie c'est de ce côté-là
qu'il faudrait écouter un peu plus et
donc nous effectivement nous sommes en
désaccord avec le fond de cette
proposition alors ça marque votre texte
au bout du compte et c'est ce qu'on vous
dit depuis le début on vous explique que
c'est un texte de droite c'est normal
c'est la nature de votre majorité donc
là c'est confirmé par l'apport de nos
collègues des républicains moi ce qui
m'interroge c'est de savoir pourquoi
vous voulez à tout prix et peut-être que
c'est les républicains qui vont nous
répondre fixer une norme pourquoi 15h
comment vous avez déterminé ce chiffre
de 15h est-ce que c'est parce que
finalement 15h c'est à peu près un
mi-temps
pour une allocation du RSA qui est à peu
près la moitié du SMIC est-ce que c'est
ça le calcul que vous avez fait sur quel
profil type vous avez établi ces 15h
c'estàdire à quoi ça correspond grosso
modo en moyenne est-ce que vous avez
fait une moyenne est-ce que voilà on
comprend pas bien et enfin la dernière
chose c'est que en procédant de la sorte
vous fixez quelque part cette norme et
vous allez imposer tend au maximum vers
de l'occupationnel parce que tout le
monde n'aura pas besoin de 15 he ça ne
correspondra pas à toutes les situations
donc tout ça en réalité est assez
incohérent et la phrase qui vient
nuancer les 15h à la suite en réalité va
être effacée par le chiffre lui-même qui
va être la partie qui ressort donc
franchement je crois que c'est une très
mauvaise décision que nous prenons avec
un nouveau durcissement du texte avec
cet amendement je vous remercie la
parole est à Madame
rousse merci madame la Présidente
15h pourquoi 15 pourquoi pas 10 pourquoi
pas 20 pourquoi pas 11 15h 15h alors
même que depuis le début vous dites que
les personnes au RSA ont besoin
d'accompagnement ce qui est d'ailleurs
une vision un peu paternalist de cette
affaire puisque dans les personnes qui
dans les personnes qui bénéficient du
RSA il y a aussi des artistes par
exemple il y a des personnes qui
travaillent dans des dans des
exploitations agricoles et qui n'ont pas
suffisamment de revenus enfin en fait le
RSA ça recouvre bien bien des réalités
et donc 15h obligatoire faute de quoi on
on radierait ou on suspendrait l'accès
au RSA et bien c'est typiquement le cœur
battant de votre loi c'est-à-dire qu'on
on impose aux personnes des devoirs sans
qu'il y ait en face suffisamment
d'obligation de l'État par exemple les
34 % de personnes qui ne bénéficient pas
du RSA aujourd'hui alors qu'elle pourrai
en avoir les droits puisqu'elle rentre
dans les critères 34 % de non recours y
y a-t-il quelque chose dans cette loi
sur le non recours rien rien y a-t-il
quelque chose sur le fait qu'on allait
accompagner les personnes pour être sûr
qu'elles puissent aller dans les
formations ou les expériences
professionnelles s'assurer qu'on leur
finance les frais de transport par
exemple il y a rien rien il n'y a que
des devoirs dans cette loi et en fait de
devoir c'est l'obligation FAI aux
personnes de fait aux personnes de
travailler pour bénéficier de l'aide
sociale c'est un renversement complet de
la philosophie du RSA qui est de dire
que finalement on on ne doit que mériter
les 607 € que l'on peut
percevoir au fil de la séance les débats
opposent frontalement la gauche unie
contre le texte et la majorité
présidentielle qui tente de trouver un
compromis avec la droite les
républicains pour faire passer sa
réforme la parole est à Monsieur de
laaporte
pas un seul pas un seul des
sous-amendements gardefou que j'ai
déposé présenté hier soir n'a été retenu
vous avez un enfant de 13 ans vous avez
des problèmes de Garne vous serez pas
exempté oui parce que c'est jusqu'à 12
ans vous vous occupez de vos prochdent
enfin vous êtes un prochent vous vous
occupez de vos parents vous vous occupez
de votre enfant handicapé de plus de 12
ans vous ne serez pas exempté des 15 à
20h c'est ça que vous allez voter c'est
ça que le gouvernement et le teur vont
vous demander de voter sans sourciller
chers collègues il y a quelques années
vous disiez on a une jambe gauche et une
jambe droite aujourd'hui on voit bien
que la jambe gauche elle est à tout le
moins fictive ou alors elle n'a jamais
existé je va rappeler je vais rappeler
je vais
rappeler je vais rappeler je vais
rappeler monsieur Maillard si vous
voulez bien les propos de votre Ministre
au Sénat il ne s'agira pas d'un travail
gratuit qui dit travail dit contrat de
travail et rémunération sachant qu'il
existe un minimum légal à respecter il
ne s'agira pas non plus d'un bénévolat
obligatoire ou imposé et cetera c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas
voulu inscrire les modalités exactes de
cette obligation dans la loi considérant
qu'il ne s'agitit pas de disposition de
nature législative il ne s'agit pas non
plus de disposition d'ordre
règlementaire c'est la séance du 10
juillet c'est ce que disait monsieur le
ministre mais décidément vous n'êtes pas
à une contortion prês le problème c'est
que derrière cette contorion il y a des
gens il y a des vies il y a des
personnes qui devront travailler 1h 2h
5h 10h et même plus que 20h puisque
monsieur le rapporteur a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de plafond à ce nombre
d'heures d'activité vous serez fier de
le
voter vous serez fier de le voter nous
serons nous serons contre cela nous
sommes pour l'accompagnement nous sommes
pour l'accompagnement monsieur mayillard
vous êtes pour mettre les gens sans RSA
et dans la galère totale je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Bazin c'est vous
après merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la Présidente de commission monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers
collègues cet amendement du groupe des
des républicains vise juste à réécrire
l'alinéa 9 il en modifie pas la la
substance il ne fait que préciser et
prendre en compte des attentes légitimes
notamment sur la situation particulière
des personnes qui nous sont confiées le
premier le premier alinéa qui vous a
proposé est très important pour nous il
est même fondamental c'est une cible de
15h cette cible de 15h pourquoi elle est
là d'avoir dans une semaine 15 he
d'action de formation d'accompagnement
de suivi ça n'a rien de choquant 15 he
dans une semaine c'est pas énorme
mais ça permet aussi d'avoir un rythme
de se donner des objectifs et d'avoir
ces actions d'accompagnement plutôt que
d'être dans l'isolement social si on
veut justement l'insertion sociale il
faut pouvoir se fixer cet objectif cette
cible qui est important le deuxième
adinéa il est important c'est qui permet
que ces 15 heur puissent être réduites
donc vous voyez on n' pas été sourd à
vos arguments et d'ailleurs nous-même
nous les avions porté pour pour prendre
en compte les
spécificités mais ce qui nous a semblé
important et nous allons soutenir le
premier amendements du Gouvernement
c'est qui est la collégialité de la
décision de manière à ce qu'on se
retrouve pas avec des décisions qui
pourrait être contesté au contraire avec
cette collégialité on assure avec les
équipes pluridisciplinaires de pouvoir
prendre en compte la réalité des
personnes le trè lire est aussi très
important puisqu'il prend en compte la
santé le handicap l'invalidité les
parents isolés sans solution de garde
donc vous voyez cet alinéa est beaucoup
cet amendement est beaucoup plus complet
beaucoup plus humain par rapport à ce
qui est proposé mais après ne vous
cachez pas derrière vos sous-amendements
et et nous soutiendrons le deuxième
sous-amendement du gouvernementos vos
autres sous-amendements sont pas des
gardes fous ce que vous voulez c'est
aucune contrepartie c'est aucune action
et nous on n'est pas d'accord parce
qu'on souhaite des droits et des devoirs
merci Monsieur
Bazin merci Monsieur Bazin la parole est
à Madame
tin je vous rappelle qu'on ne claque pas
les doigts l' Assemblée je vous
remercie allez-y madame
otin non claque pas les doigts c'est
juste une c'est juste voilà c'est juste
une question de savoir vivre je vous
remercie allez-y madame
otin c'est juste du respect on ne claque
pas des doigts monsieur ça s'arrête là
mais s'il faut vous le redire en fait je
vous le redirai à foison allez-y madame
otin allez on continue s'il vous plaît
allez-y nous sommes mes chers collègues
au cœur au cœur de ce projet de loi de
son
sens vous allez-y vous avez mis madame
la Présidente voilà je recommence parce
que allez-y
avec votre savoirvvre vous avez mis le
bazar là je vous remercie allez-y merci
madame la Présidente nous arrivons ici
au cœur de ce projet de loi avec cette
idée que au fond celles et ceux qui sont
RSA sont dé feignants et qu'il faut les
mettre d'urgence au travail pour un
revenu je le rappelle un revenu qui est
de 600 de 604 € c'est la réalité donc
ces femmes et ces hommes ces femmes et
ces hommes devrait avoir droit à une
prestation sociale inconditionnelle qui
est une garantie pour vivre à minima et
c'est encore en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté au lieu de vous attaquer aux
grands groupes économiques aux hyper
riches auxquels vous faites des
largesses en permanence sans demander la
moindre contrepartie ce sont au plus
fragiles aux plus vulnérables que vous
demandez des comptes que vous montrez du
droit et avec un dispositif dont nous
comprenons toujours pas à cette heure
quelles sont les bornes monsieur le
ministre vous avez dit au démarrage
c'est entre 15 et 20h puis là nous avons
un amendement qui dit c'est 15h mais 15h
en étant un minimum sans savoir quel est
le maximum puis tout à l'heure j'entends
du rapporteur que au fond il s'agit
d'une cible mais il y a des amendements
ici qui sont déposés dans lequel il est
écrit que la cible est 15h donc ça peut
être en dessous de 15h donc est-ce qu'on
peut avoir quelque chose de clair
notamment de la part du ministre mais
aussi de la part du rapporteur pour nous
dire quel est le minimum et quel est le
maximum parce que pour l'instant c'est
d'un flou total la seule chose que nous
savons c'est que vous voulez forcer ces
gens à travailler or or deux chose
d'abord une partie pourrait en être
exclu les femmes les mères isolées
notamment mais que s'ils ont des enfants
si elles ont des enfants de moins de de
12 ans mais alors tous ceux qui et toute
celle qui s'occupent d'autres proches
qui sont en difficulté qui ont besoin
d'aide c'est rien du tout c'est rien du
tout et par ailleurs il y en a qui
travaille je termine juste d'un mot
beaucoup qui touchent le RSA travaille
dans le tissu associatif sont
agriculteur mais ne peuvent pas se payer
sont artistes et ne peuvent pas trouver
un endroit pour exercer alors vous
déz la parole est à Monsieur
[Applaudissements]
deini merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre ça fait plusieurs
fois plusieurs amendements qu'on vous
dépose et dans lesquels on vous dit
qu'il y a un problème avec vos 15 heures
d'activité parce qu'elle ne
correspondent à rien par parfis dans
certains parcours il faut moins en
premier temps d'heur d' de d'activité
parfois il en faudra plus et l'activité
le terme d'activité lui-même je le
rappelle n'est toujours pas défini on ne
sait toujours pas à quoi ça correspond
je repose ma question une anème fois
mais est-ce que dans le cadre du de la
de la reprise de confiance en soi est-ce
qu'elle est chez le coiffeur ou est-ce
qu'elle est dans une salle de sport ça
va être considéré comme une activité
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par activité
parce qu'il y a des personnes qui ne
sont qui euh travaillent et qui sont au
RSA parce que pour le moment leur
situation ne leur permet pas de subvenir
à leurs besoins je pense notamment aux
auto-entrepreneurs par exemple qui sont
en activité eux travaillent et là ils
vont devoir parmi les trouver 15 heures
par semaine pour avoir une activité
c'est incohérent donc il faudrait quand
même monsieur le ministre que vous
réfléchissiez si on est tous sur ces
bancs à vous dire qu'il y a un problème
avec ça c'est que peut-être il y en a un
et peut-être il faut
écouter si la parole est madame bergant
allez-y merci madame la présidente
depuis le début nous voyons bien que
certains de nos collègues ont une vision
très très caricaturale très premier
degré si je puis dire puisque vous
bloquez vraiment sur les 15h euh or les
rapporteurs et Monsieur le Ministre
n'ont cessé d'expliquer tout au long de
ces heures de débat que nous faisons le
pari de l'accompagnement adapté
l'accompagnement adapté en fonction
évidemment la situation des personnes
donc les situations de mobilité de
monoparentalité de prochédents d'accès
aux soins sont évidemment prises en
compte je trouve que que l'amendement de
notre collègue Juvin est en réalité un
amendement équilibré car oui il évoque
les 15h comme un objectif et c'est bien
l'objet premier de ce texte l'ambition
de ce texte oui préciser que les 15h
sont un objectif mais que le nombre
peut-être réduit adapté à la situation
c'est prendre en compte les situations
personnel des demandeurs d'emploi euh et
oui il faut préciser qu'il doit y avoir
un accompagnement minimal et qu'on ne
peut pas se contenter d'abandonner
certaines personnes au bord de la route
en ne leur proposant aucun
accompagnement donc oui je trouve que c
amendement est un amendement équilibré
bra je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
saintuille pour nous puis nous passerons
au voix
allez-y merci Madame la Présidente je
vais redémarrer sur le propos de Madame
bergand
modem ça va le modem
oua en commission en commission chers
collègues vous avez défendu la
progressivité vous avez défendu l'idée
que des 15h c'était une base qui n'avait
pas de fondement sérieux et que du coup
il faudrait créer les conditions de la
progressivité mais la magie de la parade
nuptiale vous amène à oublier cette
hypothèse de la progressivité pour
finalement nous dire que c'est un ement
équilibré très honnêtement la
pierrouette est visible par tous c'est
un peu surprenant mais bon qu'est-ce que
vous voulez ça fait partie du jeu moi je
veux relever un
instant la problématique que vous n'avez
pas voulu traiter monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre on vous a fait une
proposition pour que 15h ce soit le
maximum déjà 15h tout le monde s'accorde
à dire même ceux qui défendent
l'hypothèse intellectuellement et
politiquement tout le monde s'accorde à
dire que ça sera très compliqué voire
impossible mais on aurait pu fixer le la
borne on le fait pas bien on vous a
proposé une durée maximum en considérant
que si un allocataire était 12 mois
renouvelabl une fois en contrat
d'engagement réciproque qu'il
s'engageait au au au 15h que vous
souhaitez qu'au bout de 2 ans s'il était
toujours en situation d'inactivité au
sens qu'il avait pas retrouvé d'emploi
alors il faudrait prendre acte qu'il y
avait une problématique plus large et
que du coup il faudrait encadrer cette
durée de manière générale et pour
terminer le group lot il a fait des
propositions sur les droits et les
devoirs je veux répondre à Monsieur
Bazin sur les droits et les devoirs on a
fait des propositions dans l'amendement
qui suivra qui sera peut-être pas
discuté c'était une bonification pour
ceux qui sont très engagés dans un dans
un engagement renforcé dans l'article 3
on nous a refusé on nous a retoqué des
sanctions que nous avions proposé sous
prétexte qu'elles étaient moins disantes
moins dures que Cell du gouvernement et
que du coup par principe elle coûterait
de l'argent et on nous a opposé le fait
que du coup ça créerait une charge c'est
pas très S Sée parce que ici il y a
peut-être une discussion sur les droits
et devoirs mais il y avait une autre
voie de passage que les droits et les
devoirs et surtout les devoirs que vous
avez présenté
aujourd'hui je vais donc mettre au voix
les amendements de cette discussion
commune alors je rappelle que l'avis du
gouvernement et de la commission est
uniquement favorable pour l'amendement
de Monsieur Juvin et les deux
sous-amendements du gouvernement nous
allons voter l'amendement numéro 183
celui de Monsieur Juvin qui a le double
avis favorable commission gouvernement
c'est un scrutin public le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
116 exprimés 115 majorités 58 pour 88
contre 27 l'Assemblée nationale
adopté après 2 semaines de débat
passionné en séance publique c'est
l'heure du vote solennel les orateurs de
chacun des 10 groupes politiques
représentés à l'Assemblée nationale se
succède à la tribune pour présenter leur
position de vote
extrait après 40h de débat 1490
amendements examinés et 138 amendements
adoptés cette mesure est le reflet de
notre engagement à poursuivre notre
objectif du plein emploi avec ce texte
mais également avec d'autres qui
suivront je pense notamment au travail
en cours avec les partenaires sociaux
sur l'emploi des seneur qui sera un
autre point capital pour arriver aux
objectifs ambitieux fixés le groupe
Horizon est apparenté soutiens
évidemment ce texte je vous en remercie
nous ne tendrons plus la main de la
solidarité sans conditions feu le revenu
de base conçu comme un socle fondamental
et inconditionnel de dignité il faudra
désormais mériter la solidarité ce texte
prépare les conditions pour que de
nombreuses personnes en France vivent
avec 0 € 0 € c'est nous ici dans le
confort d'un hémicycle tapissé de vux
lourd sécurisé par des indemnités
confortables qui allont décider qu'une
personne un humain pourra vivre sans
aucune ressource tel est le vote qui se
présente à
nous après ce vote solennel députés et
sénateurs se réunissent pour tenter de
trouver une version de compromis du
projet de loi à l'issue de ce h clos
fumée blanche un accord est trouvé sur
le texte le 14 novembre l'Assemblée
nationale vote de façon définitive le
projet de loi le débat
s'achève il y aura une belle enseigne
toute neuve un truc qui clignote un truc
qui
flash BIM
franceurbain dans tout le pays et en
dessous on écrira un slogan le truc que
le président avait dit et qu'on savait
pas trop ce que
c'était on vous explique en fait on
essaye on inscrit un max de monde sur la
liste des demandeurs d'emploi et
pourquoi pas leur conjoints ou conjointe
avec on leur fait signer un contrat
d'engagement dans lequel on leur file
une bonne quinzaine d'heure d'activité
obligatoire on sait pas trop lesquels
mais ça leur fera les pieds on les
contrôle on les contraint à accepter une
offre d'emploi fissa sinon qu quick on
coupe pour défendre ce projet ces
promoteurs nous ont expliqué que c'était
pour le bien des gens pour les accompagn
nous n'avons pas la même définition du
mot accompagner après avoir stigmatisé
nos seigneors et désenchanté l'avenir de
nos jeunes le gouvernement souhaite
aujourd'hui continuer de martyriser les
Français en s'attaquant cette fois-ci
aux demandeurs d'emploi et aux
allocataires du RSA vous nous demandez
aujourd'hui de voter pour un projet de
loi plein emploi qui n'emporte que le
nom un nouveau texte sur l'emploi une
nouvelle chance pour vous de rattraper
vos erreurs du passé une nouvelle chance
pour vous de traiter de la question des
salaires et de la baisse continue du
pouvoir d'achat une nouvelle chance pour
vous dev vreer contre la précarité des
jeunes et la difficulté des seiors à
trouver un emploi une nouvelle chance
pour vous de réformer efficacement la
gouvernance des pouvoirs publics en
matière d'emploi loin de saisir votre
chance vous nous n décevez une fois de
plus et osez nous proposer un texte au
profond de lacune 1,7 million d'emplois
créés 200 usine ouverte près d'un
million d'apprentis un taux d'emploi à
près de 70 % 7 % de taux de chômage qui
a été réduit de 19 à 12 pour les
personnes en situation de handicap ces
résultats sont le fruit d'une politique
constante depuis 2017 pour sortir notre
pays de la fatalité du chômage de masse
en s'attaquant à tous les freinsid
nous saluons tous nos travailleurs et
chefs d'entreprise de France ainsi que
les le travail de terrain de Pôle emploi
des missions locales de nos
collectivités de tous les acteurs de
l'insertion qui on part dans ces
résultats si le plein emploi est d'ors
et déjà une réalité dans certains
territoires le combat n'est pas terminé
il devient même de plus en plus dur à
mesure que l'on va s'approcher de la
barre des 5 % pour aller chercher les
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
tout particulièrement dans nos quartiers
tout particulièrement dans nos ruralités
dans nos outr au groupe démocrate et
plus largement dans cette majorité nous
avons la profonde conviction que
l'emploi est un moyen puissant de lutter
contre la pauvreté d'abord et de
travailler ensuite tout le cortège des
conséquences qui sont
liés l'emploi est pour nous aussi un
facteur d'intégration et de cohésion
sociale il donne une place à chacun dans
notre société et permet de financer nos
politiques de solidarité qui sont au
cœur de notre modèle social
l'emploi donc était un fil rouge de
l'action des gouvernements depuis 2017
favoriser la formation professionnelle
réindustrialiser la France lever les
verrous administratifs de l'emploi
diffuser largement l'apprentissage ont
été autant de politiques cohérentes
autour de l'emploi alors pourquoi
inscrire automatiquement ces femmes ou
plus largement tous ces conjoints
d'allocataire à emploi mal renommé
France travail je pense également aux
agriculteurs qui travaillent déjà
beaucoup que dire également de ces
allocataires qui pour 40 % d'entre eux
travaillent déjà et que vous jetez à la
vindicte populaire en les faisant passer
pour déparer ce avec vos 15 heures
d'activité obligatoire que vais-je
répondre à Pierre qui m'écrivait il y a
pas plus longtemps qu'hier qu'il
estimait que vous le poussez aller
gagner des misères dans des emplois
instable et mal payé en ajoutant du
stress plutôt que de l'EN soulager ou
encore à Magali qui en faisant une
formation financée par Paul emploi
stoppé par l'organisme de formation
reçoit un mail de désinscription et se
retrouvent aujourd'hui sans revenu
que vais-je enfin répondre à emmanuelam
IR toutes ces personnes qui bataillent
pour maintenir la tête hors de l'eau
mais que vous refusez d'entendre aussi
et qui démoignne pourtant des
défaillances du système nous en sommes
là parce que trop d'impôt et trop de
taxes parce que nous dépensons trop
parce que nous dépensons mal et parce
que aussi nous ne travaillons pas assez
alors oui ce débat était nécessaire
parce que ce débat sur le RSA c'est en
fait le débat sur le
travail les
républain nous pensons qu'une partie de
notre système social est dévoyé et
désincite au travail au lieu de ramener
vers le travail avec cette lo sur le RSA
nous vouons une chose très simple que
tous ceux qui peuvent travailler
trava quand on reçoit le RSA on a le
devoir de s'engager dans une démarche
d'insertion vers le travail et j'oute
que la société a le droit de contrôler
que vous respectez cette obligation
parce que l'argent du RSA ce n'est pas
un argent magique ce n'est pas l'argent
de l'État c'est l'argent de ceux qui
travaillent et de ceux qui cotisent
alors oui je vous le dis tranquillement
les Français qui travaillent et les
Français qui cotisent ils ont le droit
de demander des comptes sur ce qu'on
fait de leur argent vous avez fait le
choix de porter ce texte à un moment
d'inflation extrêmement important alors
que les prix continuent à galoper et que
le pouvoir d'achat est est largement
fragilisé tout au long de ce texte nous
avons fait en sorte de faire des
propositions qui correspondent à notre
philosophie celle qui croit au mérite
celle qui croit au travail celle qui
n'affaiblit pas ceux qui sont déjà dans
la fragilité par cette loi vous allez
inscrire de forces à France travail expo
l'emploi les bénéficiaires du RSA et
leur conjointte et leur conjoint les
jeunes d'missions local les personnes en
situation de handicap et aviez même
prévu comble de l'Absurdie d'inscrire
d'office les personnes en invalidité la
France mes chers collègues compte que
300000 emplois non pourvus et 7,5
million de chômeurs nous allons nous
allons à présent procéder au scrutin je
vous demande de bien vouloir regagner
vos
places le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
568 exprimé
561 majorité 281 pour 310 contre 251
l'Assemblée nationale a
[Applaudissements]
adopté après ce vote à l'Assemblée
nationale députés et sénateurs se
réunissent pour tenter de trouver une
version de compromis sur le projet de
loi à l'issue du HCl la fumée blanche
sort accord sur le texte un dernier vote
à lieu à l'Assemblée le 14
novembre je mets donc au voix le projet
de loi merci de regagner vos places le
scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
de 130 exprimé 164 majorité 83 pour 97
contre 67 l'Assemblée nationale à
adopté voilà donc pour ces morceaux
choisis et commentés du projet de loi
pour le plein emploi définitivement
adopté on se retrouve très bientôt pour
revoir une autre séance à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est la fin de ce numéro des
grand débat à très bientôt sur
LCP
[Musique]